the PC gaming ecosystem is easily the
largest in the industry with tens of
thousands of games available to play Not
only that unlike switch or Playstation
there isn't exactly a first party
publisher on PC which means there are a
few true Marquee exclusive games on the
platform but in cases where
multi-platform games do appear we
believe that they're best played on PC
and deserve a spot on this list
at first glance neon white can be hard
to comprehend I mean I have no idea
what's going on here with its first
person gameplay that mixes speed running
in a castle-like heaven World along with
a card based mechanic the game may not
seem initially intuitive like who knows
what to do with cards I certainly don't
yet once you dive into the world of the
game it quickly becomes one of the most
fluid experiences out there the beauty
of neon white is in its details as it's
quickly obvious how subtly wonderful its
design is at full speed leaping sliding
and air dashing all to shave off
milliseconds provides an arcade-like
experience and thrill on its own and the
added wrinkle of Gunplay allows for
plenty of right answers to be discovered
on the way to neon white leaderboards
immortality despite each level only
lasting a few minutes at most sometimes
even a few seconds you'll lose hours to
it as you keep trying to one-up your
previous best time I literally lost an
entire night just trying to get one more
second shaved off of my time and earned
that platinum trophy there's nothing
else quite like it and you'll be doing
yourself a massive disservice if you
don't at least give it a try
if you've ever appreciated the before
and after visual differences of mowing a
lawn mopping a floor or of course power
washing a shed then power wash simulator
is the game for you my friend in power
wash simulator you're kick-starting your
business as a power washer for hire
taking your incredibly powerful hoses to
any backyard or garage that's paying
there's something so simple yet
gratifying in watching the grime
Disappear by your hands and the game
cleverly offers a depth that takes it to
the next level but as lighthearted as it
feels its simulation gameplay is quite
detailed and when played in Co-op
especially you'll likely find an
appreciation for its strangely soothing
gameplay loop at its best power wash
simulator is a quiet relaxing experience
that's best enjoyed in small doses it's
time consuming yes but once in a while
we all need something to consume our
time
in the case of the golden idol many
players have found The Heir Apparent to
return of the Opera Dean it's a game
that devilishly obscures the truth from
you at every turn which makes uncovering
its many Secrets all the more satisfying
with a unique and even bizarre art style
the mystery game is as visually striking
as it is confounding if played with all
the answers you could see the whole game
in under two hours but to do it that way
would rob you of what makes golden idol
so memorable golden idol is a game that
quickly teaches you to think for
yourself you'll explore the
point-and-click world through several
differently styled puzzles including
interviewing Witnesses and judging their
claims piecing together notes that are
missing key information and simply
reading items like notes and newspapers
that can peel out context until
eventually you have your aha moment the
entire game feels like one big notebook
of Clues allowing you to comb through
each one on hand until the mystery is
unraveled
with the studios returning Wallace and
grommet-esque art style a sense of humor
and lightheartedness seen in every
corner of the game and a deep Suite of
features and mechanic two-point campus
takes the Sim genre to The Fairly novel
territory of a school campus and makes
it compelling for old and new players
alike building and organizing a
successful college campus could have
been the entire game but two point
Studios adds a clever depth to the
experience like managing the school's
party aspect as much as you do in your
academic intentions happy students means
tuition payments are flowing in so
creating the classroom and dorm rooms
they expect to find are Paramount and
you can create the college experience
that your college payments didn't pay
for but every college kid wants to let
loose once in a while at least and
striking that balance between
prestigious University and wild party
school makes two-point campus a funny
and sometimes unpredictable entry into
the Sim genre
two years after Call of Duty Warzone
heralded the dominating franchise's step
into the Battle Royale genre its sequel
is here to give us new modes and a new
map where the original war zone felt
like a greatest hits compilation of past
Call of Duty games war zone 2 takes
those ideas and refines them as well as
giving you a new DMZ mode a loot and
extract sandbox mode having you fight
hordes of NPCs and attempting to
infiltrate strongholds with teammates
however since Warzone 2 is new there's
still some refining to be done with
connection issues still being a problem
for some however if you're willing to
overlook the rough edges war zone 2
promises to be fun in many ways
OverWatch 2 is an extension of the
original game but that's no bad thing
OverWatch 2 did make the controversial
decision to take the series free to play
which has certainly come with its
caveats including monetization and grind
yet this also comes with increased
availability to those who can't pay up
front or at all and if you can Overlook
or ignore are those elements the base of
what makes OverWatch as a franchise
great is still here all of your favorite
heroes are in the game and this
team-based shooter still feels slick and
refined to play every character feels
unique in how to play them and they also
still have an amazing personality behind
each and every one more importantly the
new additions help push OverWatch
forward as a series the new 5v5 combat
mode shrinks each team by one and Alters
the Dynamics of the fight encouraging a
much more linked team Dynamic further
the four new heroes are all excellently
designed while certainly OverWatch 2
didn't reinvent the wheel it didn't need
to to continue the series excellent
experience
Warhammer 40K dark tide is an excellent
addition to the horde-like co-op shooter
genre first and foremost the game
excellently mixes both ranged and Close
Quarters combat enemies feel weighty and
while you can try to take them out with
the game's array of ranged weapons
including electricity influenced
projectiles and assault rifles it's when
they get in close and force you to rely
on hacking and sword fighting that the
game truly feels alive the game also has
a great balance between classes forcing
you to be aware of the positives and
negatives of your choices for Warhammer
40K fans you'll definitely get a full
experience from dark tide
return to Monkey Island
the classic Point Adventure series
Monkey Island has garnered a
well-deserved place in the annals of
video game history yet it seemed like it
might remain locked in the past for the
rest of time this is why these series
return after over two decades was a true
moment for celebration and this
unexpected sequel certainly delivered
return to Monkey Island is tinged with
Nostalgia building upon the traditional
2D point-and-click Adventure style of
gameplay from Miley obtuse puzzle
solving to quirky storytelling the story
is heartwarming and tugs at the
heartstrings and it will make series
fans feel satisfied a tall feat for a
game this long in the making even
further the game is welcome to newcomers
who might find it difficult to step into
the series adding in an optional hint
system that slightly nudges you in the
right direction overall return to Monkey
Island is a welcome return to an iconic
Video Game World
the best way to describe little to the
left is cozy the game is a delightful
puzzle game centered around a
mischievous little Scamp cat who likes
to mess up your orderly world of
household items much like real cats do
each puzzle has you trying to organize
and sort your home as you try to avoid
your feline friend leading to some fun
moments as you discover the best way to
sort poke or Pride your way to the
solution it's a Charming game that will
leave you feeling satisfied at the end
of every play session
and that's our list of the best games on
PC in 2022 yet if you want to check out
what's happening on the console side
don't forget to subscribe to Gamespot so
you can check out our list of the best
PlayStation switch and Xbox games as
well as our game of the year
foreign